we're not going to talk about standard
deviation
it's a very important concept you'll
hear about it in statistics and probably
other courses as well
very closely related to the ideas we've
been looking at we'll look at it in the
context of
vectors and considering vectors
collections of numbers
okay so if i have a vector x it's an n
vector
the average of the vector is the average
of the entries so it's the
uh it's one transpose x sorry inner
product of one and x which you now
recognize as the sum of the entries in x
and then divided by n so that's the
average so it tells you what the average
value
what the average of the coefficients is
okay
now d mean vector oh and i should say
that this is not
that's not standard no that's not
universally accepted standard notation
so
i mean someone would probably figure out
what it means if you wrote this down
but just to let you know okay and then
the idea of a d mean vector is very
interesting it says you take the vector
x and you subtract the mean value from
each entry
of it that's called the d meaned vector
we're going to denote that as x tilde
and it's x minus
the average of x that's a number which
is the average value of the entries
times one so that's the vector of
all ones uh it all entries one so
the average of the average value of x
tilde
is zero right because you've subtracted
the average and so on
um this allows us to talk about what the
standard deviation is
the standard deviation is is nothing
more than the rms value
of the demeaned vector and if you want
to write it out in all its glory it
looks like this it's x
minus inner product of 1 and x divided
by n you'll recognize this part
this part here as the average value
times
once that's when you multiply a vector
times once you get a vector with
all entries equal to this number the
average
and it says subtract that from x and
then take the norm
then divide by square root n which gives
you the rms value
that's the so-called standard deviation
and what it is it's a measure of the
typical amount by which x i varies from
its average
so if i have these x's um and
you know the standard deviation is 2.6
it says that whatever the mean is let's
suppose the mean is
seven it says we would expect
the the entries to range between
let's you know between let's see from
if the mean is is five it would go up to
uh
seven eight nine you know and down to
two or three but
it would you wouldn't have numbers that
were crazy it would be around that
average value
okay and the typical deviation would be
this standard deviation
now a vector has standard deviation zero
let's see what that means
what it means is that this is zero this
quantity up here
that only happens if x is equal to its
average
times ones and that means x is constant
so a constant vector means it's a
multiple of the ones vector
that means all the entries are always
the same and that has standard deviation
zero and that's perfectly interpretable
because if i give you a vector all of
whose entries are the same and i say
how much do they typically vary
from the mean value the answer is
they're identical to all of them are
identical to mean value
so they don't vary at all so that that
kind of makes sense that's what it means
to be stan
to have standard deviation zero um now
just as a side note um you know very
common ways to denote the mean
and standard deviation are uh the greek
letters uh mu
and sigma and i guess they stand for
mean
mu and sigma stands for the standard
deviation
okay so that's um and these are
these are also very widely used across
applied mathematics probabilities
statistics and other areas
okay now there's a basic formula
relating these con
these the different quantities we have
and that's this is that the
rms value of a vector squared
is equal to the average of the vector
squared
plus the standard deviation squared now
i'm not going to show that formula
although it's a pretty
quick derivation but i you know i don't
know you probably don't want to see me
doing some algebra on my little
pad here but it is actually a good thing
for you to try to show yourself
um it's a it's a great exercise um
and you'll use a couple of the
properties of the inner product
there to to show that um okay
now this comes up um well it's at the
heart of a lot of quantitative finance
so um let's see what that is let's
suppose that
x is a time series of returns um and it
means in each period you know
did did a dollar of investment go up in
which you know or did it go down
that kind of thing and so it's just a
time series of returns
um on some investment um over some
period
right so uh well over n periods i should
say uh oh
because each each entry is going to be a
it's going to be a a return at in a
certain time period
okay so uh that that's what it is
uh and so you know let's suppose it's
it's i mean it doesn't matter but it's
going to look like
it's going to look like this let's say
it looks like this it's
you know 0.05 minus 0.03
0.11 and minus
0.2 two that's a lot okay well too bad i
already wrote it all right here it is
so this is what it says this says in the
first period you made five percent
well it's okay that's decent in the next
period you lost three percent
and the next period you made 11 that's
like
great that's awesome and then
unfortunately on the next step you lost
okay so this is an example of a of a of
a time series of returns
okay now if i take the average
um then what i get is the mean return
of of that uh of of that asset or
investment
that's the mean return um and it's the
mean return per period
right so usually those are converted to
annual but just
it's perp it's just what it means the
mean return per period okay
and that's usually often just called the
return right so i'd say what was the
return of that
you know over the last year and somebody
would tell me you know
daily okay now standard
deviation of a return time series super
interesting
it tells you basically typically how
much
did the return deviate
from the average right so uh for example
if it looked like this
0.01 you know 0.001
whoop uh and all the entries
are 0.01 it's awesome you'd say what was
the mean return you go
one percent and you go what was the
standard deviation and the answer is
zero and what that so we we interpret
that as
sort of risk it means that you were
guaranteed to make
you know whatever it was one percent in
each time period period that was never
higher it was never lower
so that this one this is actually
referred to as just the risk
the standard deviation of the return
time series and
and what you do is you'll usually
compare these
this is how you compare uh different uh
different time series um i mean have to
be yeah this is how you compare
different time series so you would say
oh my portfolio made
you know uh over that time period it had
an average return of 12
you know let's say per year um and i had
a standard deviation
of 10 okay
so and we can interpret that that means
that we should not be surprised
if the return in any one period would be
certainly plus or minus uh
we here the people would say it is one
sigma that would be the slang
so you'd say so we should hardly be
surprised so we might have a year in
there where we did 25
we might also have one where we did
where we lost money that's a negative
number so
okay um and then these are often plotted
on a risk return plot
okay so which gives you the two the two
attributes of a return
of a return uh time series okay
so here's an example um i guess i've got
like i don't know ten
maybe this is ten periods yeah this is
ten periods and
here here are my returns okay so this
one
you know that's what is that that's like
the tur the tortoise or something okay
so here's the tortoise
and it's just it's boring it just you
get you know you get a return
of one i don't know what is one percent
it doesn't the units don't matter
it's just a steady return it's you know
the average is one
and the standard deviation is zero so in
fact uh what people would then say is
it's something like it's riskless
that there's no it's just every year
it's the same there's there's no
question
what it's going to be now this one
that's kind of interesting uh let's look
at that return time series it says that
you know in the first you know in the
first time period let's say
you made five percent you're laughing at
the person who had
this this other uh that this other
investment because you say i just
i just i just made a return five times
what you made okay
um on the next period you make about one
right that's that's this one and then on
the third period here you'll lose money
right so um and then i guess at that
point this one's laughing
and saying ha i'm always making one
percent but i've never lost when i'm not
going to lose money anyway
okay here's another one over here
another one
and you know your eyeball sees that some
of these c's are even larger
more extreme so your eyeball at least
tells you that maybe the
the the risk or standard deviation is
higher
and here's a here's a final one d and
you know we can almost see that d
is bad visually right because for
example in the first four periods
you lose money the return is negative
you lose okay
then all of a sudden you make a bunch
then you lose again twice then you make
a bunch more and
okay so um if you work out what the
what the mean of these are and the
standard deviation which we return
refers to risk uh return and risk uh
respectively
now we scatter now we plot them right
and so that would look like this this is
a very famous plot in finance
um so this is the that's the mean return
there um and that is the risk and
just to give you the rough idea uh
although this is not part of that now
it's just to show you that the concepts
we have like standard deviation
come up in real things in this case in
finance um
so i mean it should be kind of obvious
that we like high
return right i'd rather make five
percent than
two percent and i would prefer that to
losing two percent
so okay so so up the the mean axis
is good right uh for risk uh people
generally prefer it to be
smaller in other words uh it's if
if you could do something like that that
would be perfect right that
would be that that's one measure of risk
there's actually a lot of
a lot of measures of risk but the truth
is this is the one that's actually
used most often okay so that's the risk
and there
small is good so here right so here's
where you want to be on a risk return
plot you want to be in the upper
left corner upper means high return
left means it's not a corner you want to
be on the upper left side
left means you did it with low risk so
that's what you want you want high
return
low risk okay and those are just these
two attributes
and so for these four um return
sequences we can see
a couple of things a comes out over here
it's got zero risk because it just
doesn't
it doesn't um yeah it doesn't uh
it's it's cons it's a concept all the
time um here's b
sure enough look at that it's got a
higher uh it's got a higher return
like you know two and a bit times as
much as the first
investment a but its risk is higher too
and that's here c has a higher return
and higher risk still
and d over here is uh
well it's kind of a sad thing right it's
got about
that that investment has only a little
tiny bit more return
than a but a has zero risk and d
has you know four units of risk so okay
so by this thing you know we don't like
d um
oh interesting question we'll come to it
later by the way is this
um which which of these is best
um it's an interesting question
um and the answer is we can't say
actually there is something we can say
if we like return to be high and risk to
be small
this is this is correct then it turns
out you can't say
if a or b or c is better you can't say
which one is better
it depends on what people would say is
your risk appetite
if someone said yeah i yes i'll take two
and a half times the return
for a risk of two i can do that um and
so
you know that that that's completely
subjective it depends on the actual
investor
um but we can say something we can say
that d
is a pre is simply a bad
that's a bad one why because look here's
a which gets
about the same return but has zero risk
as opposed to whatever four units of
risk
right so that so the name for something
like that
is uh let's see the name for that is you
would say it is dominated by the others
right so it is dominated by the
investments you know a b and c
um but basically it's just it's crappy
that's the technical term for
for what the investment d is um
okay so this is just to tell you that
standard deviation mean
these are kind of the staples of of
quantitative finance
so the chebychev inequality can be
transposed
to handle to talk about standard
deviation and there
it's very interesting and this is
something you should just remember like
period this is
this is the right way to remember the
chebychev inequality in my opinion
so suppose you have an n vector x
it's got a it's got an average uh which
is just average of x and standard
deviation which is standard of x
okay now the uh rough idea
is that the the entries you know average
of x is sort of like
the middle point or whatever it's some
it's a typical value
right the standard deviation tells you
how much the entries
you know are above and below the the
average so
um what this says is if you would like
to know
um this is what fraction of the entries
are away from the average by
alpha standard deviations that's how
people would say this
that is no more than one over alpha
squared that's that's what it means
that's for alpha bigger than one
um i mean it holds for alpha less than
one but it's not interesting um
okay um now here's here's a very
specific example
is for any return time series with a
mean of eight percent
and a standard deviation of three
percent a loss
and that that responds to x i being less
than or equal to zero
that can occur no more than 3 8 squared
which is about 14
of the periods that's it so uh
that tells you that by the way this it
uses it's just a chebychev inequality
but you you kind of get the idea and so
the way people think of that in their
head is roughly something like this
you know most entries of the vector are
between plus and minus
you know um one standard dev one and a
half standard two standard deviations
that that's kind of now by the way don't
if you have had a course on probability
don't confuse this with like a normal
approximation or something which gives
you something
something different right this is the
chebychev that holds for this inequality
holds
has nothing to do with probability or
distributions or anything